let's get some inside analysis now home
Daniel Zimmer who's an expert on
antitrust regulations so Daniel thank
you very much for coming in to talk to
us um I just want to get another example
of monopoly or potential monopoly and
you were the chairman of Germany's
monopoly Commission until a particularly
controversial case maybe you can tell us
thank you
the case was about the German
supermarket business the strongest
company in the field
Atika wanted to take over a smaller
competitor that was present in certain
distinct regional markets and this
merger was prohibited by the federal
competition Authority later however it
was approved by by the Federal Minister
who overruled the authority's decision
okay so going against what the expert
advice essentially so what do you see as
the firm's which pose the biggest
anti-competitive threat today
competition in so-called digital markets
is a tricky issue I think we should have
an eye on Facebook in particular this
platform does not only have a huge
market share it's also difficult for
users to evade because if all your
friends are on Facebook you would have
to convince them to switch with you to
another network and then those friends
would have to need to convince their
friends in turn so we see that there is
an important log in effect does not
Facebook's fault that's of course not
Facebook's Forge but it's difficult to
evade I think with many services it's
easier to evade you can use a different
search engine of the competitors just
one click away but perhaps people are
convinced that they get to the best
service with Google but if you are once
in the social network it becomes more
difficult to switch to another one okay
but let me put this to you that
monopolies can actually be advantageous
so they get there because they provided
a fantastic service for
and who wants to really go without
Google's accurate search engine on
Facebook's newsfeed so some services
which are free to the user have big
advantages over other services
maybe monopoly is not always a bad thing
I agree I hope you agree and I think
that it's just the size of some
platforms that can create benefits for
consumers the most important search
engine knows more and knows better about
people's interests and needs so it can
provide better search results and of
course the one huge social network has
its advantages for its users the
question is whether the stretch because
of this and also how to regulate these
firms because I imagine regulating
modern digital firms is very different
from regulating the old style and
offline thought as you just mentioned
there are advantages to scale economies
of scale quality advantages but the
crucial issue is to protect the
potential of competition as long as a
monopolist or quasi monopolist is
subject to a threat that there is
potential or actual competitor around
the corner who could take over the
market or who could take over parts of
the market the monopolist will have an
incentive to serve its clients well when
this is no longer the case it becomes
difficult and dangerous and so I think
competition law should aim for
protecting this potential of competition
by for example preventing firms from
buying their direct competitors okay all
right fascinating conversation and
fascinating inside Daniel Zimmer the
former head of the German monopolies
Commission thank you very much thank you